so octopuses use its arm to explore when
people have wondered about this for a
while how they are using those arms to
do this how they're finding things in
the seafloor octopuses feel their way to
a tasty meal but for a long time
researchers have believed there is more
than touch going on such taste senses is
the term that combines elements of
mechanical sensitivity and also chemical
sensitivity now researchers think
they're uncovering the molecular
mechanism behind this proposed
chemotactile sense how does this parent
chemotactile sense work what are the
cells what are the molecules and how
does the animal use them to interact
with its world and their work is opening
a new window into how sensory systems
evolve and how those systems impact
Behavior octopuses are excellent model
systems to understand how molecular
Evolution affects the sensory systems of
animals
octopuses experience the world very
differently from humans certainly there
are some things that are familiar we
know that octopus are visual animals and
they'll use their eyes but what's really
striking about them is the way they use
those sort of enigmatic eight arms that
they they have and they're using those
to really reach into cracks in the sea
floor to probe around to surfaces or
areas that aren't accessible to things
like their eyes that maybe they can't
see into octopuses appear to be able to
accept or reject potential prey using
only their arms and it was this behavior
that led researchers to investigate
their sensory capabilities there were
some very early studies from the 1960s
that showed what looked like sensory
cells in the epithelium of the sucker
cups and that was one of the things that
got us curious in the first place that
yeah it seems like maybe there's a bona
fide sensory system housed within the
arms and the sucker cups
um but we don't know anything about how
it works but the publication of the
first octopus genome in 2015 has led to
new studies including Research into gene
expression profiles in different parts
of the octopus the rationale here is
that the sensory receptors we're looking
for should be more abundant in the rims
of the sucker cups versus other places
in octopus and what was really striking
to us was that instead of a single
receptor or a couple receptors we
identified an entire family of these
chemotactile receptors but the receptors
they identified which they call
chemotactile reception or CRS didn't
look like the kind of receptors usually
seen in sensory systems they didn't
resemble known sensory receptors instead
they're they're most closely related to
a family of receptors called nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors are found
throughout the nervous system of many
different animals but usually they
detect neurotransmitters within the body
and are involved with things like
controlling muscle contractions
in humans that a focus of research into
treatments for everything from
Parkinson's disease to nicotine
addiction
but they are not sensory receptors
or so researchers fought in the course
of their evolution octopus have
converted these ancestral nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors into sensory
receptors they look almost identical at
first glance and it wasn't until we
looked closer that we started to
appreciate some of the structural
regions that are mediating these
functional differences the team imaged
the octopus receptors using
cryo-electron microscopy and compared to
structure they found with the nicotinic
receptors found commonly in other
animals and they found a subtle but very
important difference in an area called
the ligand binding site this is where
the receptor binds with its chemical
partner in nicotinic receptors this is a
cage-like structure that binds with
neurotransmitters like acetylcholine
causing its ION channel to open and
transmit signals
but the octopus receptors are different
instead of a cage they've evolved to
have a shallow Groove and that allows
for a wider range of materials to bind
in particular materials that don't mix
well with water like the kinds of greasy
residues left on the sea floor by
potential prey a useful tool in a hunt
we describe this as being a chemo
tactile sense which basically combines
chemo sensation sensation of chemicals
who have tactile sensation or touch this
clarified picture of the molecular
mechanism behind taste by touch helps
explain some of the octopus's unique
behaviors especially when compared to
the structures of the same types of
receptor in related animals like squid
octopuses use their chemotic receptors
for their exploratory predation Behavior
interestingly octopus and squid have a
different predatory strategy instead of
using its arm for exploration rather
squid and Bush Predator hide strike and
pull their potential prey and then
decide to eat or reject it this
behavioral difference the researchers
say can be explained by their different
receptors
for example the octopus receptors
wouldn't work in the Open Water the
types of chemicals that they're actually
able to sense are very hydrophobic
molecules things that you would not
expect to find in the water column in a
marine environment and things that
instead you would expect to find on the
surfaces in a marine environment so it
makes sense that they would have to
physically touch them and contrary the
square
greasy molecules instead it responds to
a bit retains that are soluble and
easily diffusive in water it explains
squids like
strikingly different predatory behavior
evolutionary differences at a molecular
level align with strikingly different
abilities and behaviors
and this is far from the end of the
story oh yeah there are there are a lot
of things we we don't understand here we
just started look at one of each
receptor from octopus and squid there
are more octopus and squid chemother
receptors with different properties May
pursue different different functions in
sensory system
for example there is evidence that some
octopus receptors can also detect
voltage but how this ability fits into
their broader sensory system is still
unknown
even within the world of The
chemotactile receptors already studied
there's much more to learn you know we
initially got into this study thinking
that we would be studying a sensory
system that's used for predation for
finding prey and while we still think
that's the case so far most of what
we've discovered relates to perversive
stimuli or things that the octopus
doesn't like
and so we're really interested to find
if somewhere in this diversity of CRS
there are receptors that mediate what we
would call repetitive sensation or you
know food things that the octopus maybe
wants to eat
or
if the octopus maybe just eats anything
unless it has a signal that says no
don't eat this researchers are gradually
building a better comprehension of how
sensory systems evolve and being able to
combine behavioral observation with
complex structural understanding give
scientists yet another piece in the
evolutionary puzzle of odd including
natalies and cuttlefish they're evolving
differently from octopus and squares so
that would be very interesting to see
how and why they're different from
uh molecular Atomic level to animal
behavior level